[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today i'm
going to be showing you the brand new
imac that apple just announced
this is a brand new 5k 27 inch retina
display model and this also has
something very
very special much like the new pro
displays that you guys have seen you now
have the option to configure this model
with a nano texture display and what
this does is it gives you that matte
finish but not just
any matte finish i have been editing on
the pro display xdr
for quite a while and the difference
between editing on that nano texture
and the regular retina on my previous
imac pro it is
honestly like night and day anyway this
is the new 27-inch
imac it's 65 faster with 6 8 and 10 core
processors there's two different
configurations for graphics
55 faster gpu you can also configure it
up to 128 gigs of ram
i love that they're now including solid
state drives across all models and you
can also configure it up to eight
terabytes and this is a really huge
upgrade especially for the imac because
i feel like a lot of people are using
this for so many different things
whether it's video editing editing
photos
even just doing zoom calls no matter
what you're doing having a solid state
drive
is so much more efficient and much
faster and again we're talking about the
regular imac not the imac pro the imac
pro is obviously geared way more towards
professionals but a lot of the things
that that imac pro has is now trickling
down into the imac
at a much lower price i feel like the
times now have shifted
so significantly to everyone working
from home and an imac i feel like is a
really great
family type computer we had imax growing
up all through when i lived with my
parents
and it was really great because that
sort of was the centerpiece
to kind of like our household and even
back then which i don't wanna it was
quite a while ago at this point and even
back then like having this computer we
would watch shows on it i would do
homework my sisters would do their
homework my dad would be reading the
news
my mom would be using it for her work so
i feel like now
even more than ever because everybody is
home having this one
sort of central device that really can
do everything
is incredible i think now the problem is
now that everybody's home
everybody's gonna want to have an imac
[Music]
even for me even though i just got this
one i still use my imac pro
a lot granted i do have one of the mac
pros and i know i'm kind of in sort of a
unique situation where my job basically
revolves around reviewing technology and
editing and production this is kind of
an
unlikely situation but the fact that i
do have a mac pro and i do sometimes end
up gravitating
towards my imac pro because it really is
all-in-one it has the webcam built in
it has incredible speakers i don't have
to do anything i just push a button
everything that i want to use with the
mac pro
it's all external so if i want to add a
webcam i have to add a microphone i have
to add
speakers so you don't get that sort of
just out of the box
ready to go and with the new imac they
did
finally upgrade the webcam i mean
this is seriously crazy because it's
something that even now like
people didn't use the webcams as much as
they do now
there has been a shortage of webcams i
bought a logitech webcam
maybe like four months ago two and a
half months later it canceled they said
that they didn't have any and they
couldn't send it to me i was like that's
crazy the things that we took for
granted before
like a webcam so having this new
upgraded webcam i think is very
important they also have an upgraded
microphone
it's studio quality it's a three mic
array it also has the haste
integration which i surprisingly do use
more than you would think i know a lot
of people myself included have come very
accustomed to being able to talk to your
devices
especially with the home pod at alexa
and google all of these things has just
made it so
simple to start talking to your devices
the speakers and the webcam are now
working in conjunction with the t2
security chip so with the webcam
it's automatically adjusting for
exposure focus
it has enhanced tone mapping it's
working with face detection
so that's to help improve a lot of the
zoom calls the
webex calls the teams meetings the face
times whatever it is that you're doing
to get through your day for work or fun
or whatever it is
so the webcam has been updated and even
in my little bit of time in testing this
you can definitely tell that it does
adjust
very quickly for exposure so it
definitely does help out if you are in
lower light situations and there's one
thing that i have noticed quite a lot
about a lot of these conference calls
that i've been on some people just
still cannot figure out finding the good
light
is very important put yourself towards a
window
or just put a little light on you it
goes a long way so the nano texture
glass that is on this imac is very
similar to the pro display xtr
and that's an extra thousand dollars
when you upgrade
the pro display and for the imac it is
an extra 500
but honestly if you are considering
getting this i can't even tell you how
incredible it looks like i you might be
just like seeing your fan girl
you're just feeding in to giving apple
more money
this is worth it especially if you do
work from home i feel like it's so much
easier on your eyes
it completely eliminates glare and
everything just looks so much more crisp
especially if you're doing photo editing
or video
it's just really hard to even explain if
you've never experienced this
i would tell you to go to the apple
store and check it out
but i coveted
also the microphone on this is really
good and i think that's one of the
things that apple has been also focusing
on
obviously with the updated microphones
in their macbook line
the speakers sound incredible i was
watching some movies and playing some
games on apple arcade i just forget how
loud those speakers can get
also with the t2 security chip it's
enhancing the balance the fidelity and
it has a deeper bass
and when i was watching some of these
shows i was putting that volume all the
way up and i was really surprised how
loud these speakers are since i do edit
a lot on my imac pro
i usually do edit at max volume so i'm
going to be editing this entire video
that you're watching here
on the imac the rest of this video is
going to be kind of a day in the life
of me and the imac back there
happy editing day so the imac is still
over here in
my studio shooting area which is a
complete disaster but welcome to the
vlog portion
of this video this is uh gonna be moved
over to a desk
so that i can start editing this video
and let's just take a moment
to remember this has an sd card slot and
that's glorious
this is true talent right here
[Music]
i already see like the nano texture so
i'm basically pointing this directly up
at my lights
and when i'm looking at this straight on
there is absolutely no glare
no reflection it's beautiful let's get
this thing powered on start editing
[Music]
a lot of stuff that i shoot like the
sit-down desk stuff is all recorded
to a solid state drive so i use the
atomos ninja 5
so we're not actually recording to sd
cards but some of the shots that my
sister got
using the edelkrone behind the scenes of
shooting the mac pro getting some cool
edelkrone shots jenna's the edelkrone
pro
it looks really cool yeah it's nice
those were actually recorded to an sd
card and right now i'm recording using
the sony zb1
i've been dying to test this camera out
in sort of a shooting vlogging situation
like this so this is kind of like a
two-part video test for me i'm testing
out the imac and also testing out the
vlogging camera but this of course is
also recording on an sd card so let's
start transferring some footage
normally i do edit off of external
drives but today i am going to edit
directly off the solid state drive
just to test out the performance and see
how it handles it
testing out that new 1080p webcam i
actually made most of my first youtube
videos
on the isight camera on one of my
macbook laptops so
me and this webcam we have a history so
in this webcam test i was purposely
putting myself
in front of the light so basically i was
making myself backlit
so normally in some of the other webcams
in this specific test
it would be trying to adjust for the
light that was behind me
in return making myself dark and not
being able to see me at all
so this seemed to handle it quite well i
look forward to doing some face time
calls on here
maybe i'll call my sister let's see what
she's doing
let's see what she's doing i'm so
nervous i'm so nervous
i hope she is
this is not jenna this is absolutely
[Music]
my sister hi oh god
you don't even know how scary that was
i thought you got kidnapped we all are
having a quarter
meet up because we're walking daddy and
we saw our friend what's the blaster you
want
i can't tell you does it look good does
it look does the device look good
it looks pretty great but like what is
that what are you doing what is it
you want a secret device maybe i don't
know does it look good
yeah well i'm also outside so like come
on wi-fi
how's my audio sound is the audio sound
good too
yeah you sound good this is great thank
you for participating um you guys have a
nice walk
all right bye see ya
bye oh
wow the device looks good
i also realized while editing that i
didn't tell you guys the specs of this
mac so this is the 3.6 gigahertz 10 core
intel core i9 it has 64 gigs of ram and
it's running the amd radeon pro 5700 xt
16 gigabyte graphics card so this is a
pretty solid imac
and things are going quite well i look
forward to seeing what you guys think of
the video and what you guys think of the
whole
imac refresh right now there's so much
happening in the world of tech so it's
always really fun to be able to get a
chance to test these out for you guys i
also
plan on moving this imac back where my
other imac was because this is my
streaming station
and all of the streams that i have been
doing over on twitch i've actually been
streaming on my imac pro
so i'm definitely going to test this out
and see how it handles all of my
streaming setups
so let's spec one of these out and just
take a look and see
so here it is oh my gosh they're doing
like a little three cam
multicam edit there so obviously this is
the 27 inch and yes they do still have
the 21 and a half inch imac this imac is
starting at
17.99 which when you think about all
that you're getting
in this all-in-one device it's pretty
incredible so here's the 21-inch
options that they currently have
available and this is the new 27-inch so
we have three different models to choose
from
oh boy there's a 3.1 gigahertz 6 core
processor
there's the 3.3 gigahertz 6 core and
that has
the turbo boost to 4.8 gigahertz with
512 gigs of storage
and then the 3.8 gigahertz eight core
processor with a turbo boost 512 gigs of
storage
so it looks like it ranges from 17.99 to
22.99
starting price for one of these nano
texture glass is an additional 500
worth it i can't wait until we have a
nano texture macbook
hello apple please sign me up
just sign me up i think i've just
completed my edit i guess i'll see you
guys in my next video
i am gonna do a streaming setup on here
so if you guys aren't subscribed to my
youtube channel already make sure you do
so
and if you enjoyed this video hit the
like and if you guys have any questions
about this imac
leave them in the comments below and i
will try to answer them in my next video
so that's it i'll see you guys later
thanks for watching